lendemain de veille sans précédent à
toronto après l'euphorie la colère tu
fais une exaspération envers les auteurs
de la fusillade un sens c'est au milieu
de la foule devant l'hôtel de ville
quatre personnes ont été blessées par
balles et quelques autres ont été
piétinées c'est un petit miracle que le
bilan ne soit plus lourd
trois suspects ont été arrêtés sur le
coup et un autre court toujours
les policiers réclament l'aide du public
une question demeure les autorités était
elle prête à accueillir deux millions de
personnes dans les rues de toronto
sauf en quelques endroits il n'y avait
pas de barrière pour contenir la foule
la marée humaine a ralenti le défilé qui
a pris trois heures de retard
des parents ont perdu leurs enfants dans
la foule des personnes déshydratées ont
perdu conscience des partisans se sont
plaints du manque d'eau et de toilettes
en plus non loin du cortège
quatre personnes ont été poignardées
c'était un événement festif explique le
chef de police en assurant qu'il y avait
suffisamment de policiers sur place on
ne voulait pas en faire un événement à
haute sécurité digne du g20 nous ne
voulions pas confiner les partisans dans
des enclos ou ajoute ce responsable
il s'agit d'incidents isolés pas d'un
oeil au beurre noir pour la réputation
des torontois et des canadiens ajoute le
ministre fédéral de la sécurité publique
les événements qui ont assombri la fête
ont aussi été vécue lors des
célébrations des champions de la nba à
cleveland et au cloud ces dernières
années a weekend preuve le maire promet
des améliorations pour la prochaine fois
oui la prochaine fois toronto habituée
aux défaites sportive s'est découvert
une confiance en soi ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto
[Applaudissements]